most people have no idea that there are
ancient sites from around the world
where something disturbingly bad
happened to thousands of years ago and
it's a total mystery and when you see
what i'm going to show you in this video
many of you will wonder how and why you
haven't seen or heard of these
incredibly bizarre details before now
many would assume that giza would have
been the capital of ancient egypt but
that is actually not the case as it was
memphis that was the long-existing
capital however for a period of time
tennis was the capital of the entire
country of egypt and the lost city of
tanis is one of those ancient sites that
most people have never even heard of
located deep within the nile delta and
is about a three and a half hour drive
from modern day giza it wasn't even
officially discovered until just over 80
years ago in 1939 after nearly 12 years
of digging and excavation by a team of
french archaeologists
but what this site looked like when it
was first came across by early explorers
who sketched it in the mid-1800s is
simply remarkable
look at the condition of what was once
the principal city of all of ancient
egypt an incredible mess of destroyed
ancient ruins including massive statues
obelisks stone blocks and everything
else it's no wonder it took more than a
decade of digging for this site to be
fully excavated
and this is what it looks like today
after many years of restoration although
restoration is certainly not the
appropriate word as the remnants have
been moved and repositioned into an
organized museum-like fashion not at all
the layout of what it would have been
originally thousands of years ago
again
just look at the utter devastation
clearly something catastrophic happened
to this site to obliterate so many
pieces of immense rose granite which by
the way is believed to originate from
the oswan quarry which is more than a
thousand kilometers or 630 miles away
and this only adds to the mystery when
you consider that there are broken
pieces of a statue made up from one
single piece of stone that is believed
to be the largest ever to have existed
and get this
it is estimated to have been 28 meters
or nearly 100 feet tall
in some 1100 tons and again
carved from one single piece of granite
how did the ancients move stone of that
mass more than a thousand kilometers and
what on earth happened to obliterated
into so many fragmented pieces
as you see these various photos of this
site is it not abundantly clear that
something devastating happened here that
far exceeds the destructive works of an
angry mob of invaders like i mentioned
tanis is located deep in the nile delta
and for some bizarre reason
this site stands out as a barren
wasteland of dirt where there's
virtually nothing green about it
almost nothing grows here why is that
and something else that's worth
mentioning is that tanis was also the
biblical city of zoan
from the old testament and you may be
curious to hear what these two bible
verses say about it quote
i will destroy the idols and put an end
to the images of memphis no longer will
there be a prince in egypt and i will
spread fear throughout the land and in
the very next verse it goes on to say
that
i will lay waste to upper egypt set fire
to zoan and inflict punishment on
thieves wow set fire to zoand that is
quite interesting especially when you
consider that some of these stones
appear to have been scorched with high
heat
which that in itself is another mystery
what would have happened to create this
level of heat damage to solid granite
and to think that this was once the
capital of all of ancient egypt and
adding on to the fact that so few have
ever even heard of this ruined place
is truly strange
so with that said what do historians
think happened to this lost city
well that is where things get even more
strange as they speculate that it was
simply abandoned some 3000 years ago
when a branch of the nile river built up
with silt and made the city's harbor
unusable
yeah okay there are multiple reasons why
that makes no logical sense
besides the fact that the entire city is
totally obliterated which is blatantly
apparent to all who have ice to see but
if tanis was indeed abandoned due to an
unusable harbor then why did they leave
all the city's valuable treasures behind
after all the excavations yielded what
is said to be one of the greatest
archaeological troves ever found from
ancient times including dazzling
funerary treasures such as golden masks
faces of silver elaborates of kapha guy
and countless remains of precious
jewelry clearly if the egyptians chose
to abandon this city because their
harbor became unusable which by the way
if they could build all this stuff why
won't they just build another harbor but
it seems to me that if nothing else they
would have taken their valuables along
with them
and i'd also argue that even if the nile
river had swelled and inundated the city
that still wouldn't explain the vast
catastrophic damage to all of these
massive stones but not only that i would
venture to say that the egyptians would
have been intelligent enough to avoid
putting their capital in a location that
would be inundated by flooding of the
nile
no there is clearly more to the story of
what happened to tanis and if anything
it looks like it was bulldozed by a
tsunami but you should know that this is
not the only site from ancient egypt
that appears to have been obliterated by
some mysteriously unknown catastrophic
event
you see abuser which is located not far
from the giza plateau is another site
that most people have never heard of
either in fact it's off limits to the
general public and is only available to
be seen by those who obtain special
access permission which requires
paperwork and literally thousands of
dollars which ultimately grants you a
heavily monitored visit with chaperones
from the egyptian ministry of
antiquities and having visited this site
personally i have to say that it appears
that something devastating happened to
this ancient temple as well
and keep in mind that the condition in
which we see it today is after many
centuries of its stone having been
removed from the site to be recycled and
reused on other structures in the area
and by the way
that is the explanation as to why the
site was destroyed in the first place to
reuse the stone
however i would argue that stone
recycling does not explain the full
nature of the devastated remnants of
this site
like i always say look and think for
yourself it seems to me that there is
more to the story of abuser and i have
to say that i am very curious as to why
this site is so shielded from the
general public to the point that you
have to pay thousands of dollars to get
special government permission to even
see it with your own eyes now there are
other sites around egypt that appear to
have been obliterated by a catastrophe
as well but what i want to show you now
are sites ancient sites all the way over
in south america that appear to have
been destroyed
in my previous video i shared and
discussed the perplexing mystery of
involving 80 ton stones that were
somehow brought a mile down a mountain
from the quarry immediately carried
across a river
transported through a valley and then
brought to the top of a steep
mountainous hill in the peruvian andes
to the ancient inca site that is called
oyante tombo if you haven't watched that
video definitely check it out after this
one as you will clearly see that
something devastating happened here as
well
as at the top of this incredible site
there are massive monolithic stone
blocks that totally stand out from the
multiple other types of stonework found
in the area at least three different
construction methods in fact which is
interesting when you consider that the
historical experts claim that this had
to have been created by the same
civilization and at the same time
but i have to say that i highly doubt
that but that aside notice how the
largest and most impressive pieces of
stone are scattered about many of which
are broken and clearly what's left over
of whatever this site was prior to its
obvious destruction yet it is claimed
that the site simply wasn't completed
they do not say it was destroyed they
say the inca just did not finish it
yeah i'm not so sure about that either
especially when you consider that at the
bottom of this mountain are the remnants
of various broken pieces of stonework
that appear to have tumbled down the
mountain long ago
and this really shouldn't be a surprise
when we consider that the andes
mountains are already known for their
powerful earthquakes that have taken
place over the millennia but earthquake
or not clearly something catastrophic
happened here but then there's the
lesser-known peruvian site of sioustani
located along lake titicaca not far from
the bolivian border
this is one of those places that
pictures simply do not do justice
the ultra ride camera lenses that are
necessary to capture the full size of
these impressive stone work also distort
the true depth of these behemoth which
with your own eyes when seen in person
is totally different
this will be a topic for another video
but right now let's focus on the obvious
destruction at this site
and although this will sound crazy it
literally appears to have been exploded
notice how these massive multi-ton stone
blocks are scattered everywhere
this is not a matter of these ruins
being deconstructed over the centuries
and stone blocks being moved around
no when you visit this site you would be
amazed to see that these massive blocks
are scattered and broken as if they were
thrown hundreds of feet into the air and
falling all around the area perhaps the
best example is what you're seeing here
these stones are at least 10 tons and if
they were carried and set down that
would not explain that the fact they are
cracked in half but pictures never do it
justice so observe this short video that
i filmed while visiting this site last
august and forgive the shaky camera and
quick panning but it paints you a
picture for what the environment looks
like surrounding the area
again look and think for yourself
does this really appear to have been
deconstructed with the stones casually
just dropped about the area some of
which by the way are a couple hundred
yards away and here's another question
to think about
why would they deconstruct it only to
rebuild with significantly smaller and
less
precise stones
i said it before and i'm saying it again
clearly there is more to the story about
these ancient sites than what's been
theorized by people in modern times many
of which have never even visited these
places in person make no mistake it is
indeed a true mystery and that is the
point of this video that there are
significant ancient sites around the
world including even a lost capital of
ancient egypt where something
unbelievably destructive happened to and
yet somehow
so few people are even aware of and i
have to say i find that fascinating
because the question becomes
what on earth happened to these sites
was it some type of massive flooding or
tsunami event or perhaps some type of
cosmic air burst in the atmosphere from
an exploded asteroid
the option there are many options so
definitely leave a comment and share
what your thoughts and insight is on
this because it will make this already
thought-provoking topic that much more
interesting but that said i'll close it
up here because this will set the stage
for other videos that i'm currently
working on
but i'm jimmy corsetti my channel is
called bright insight hit the like
button and subscribe and i have many
more interesting videos to come real
soon
take care everybody